they took a risk to come out to the
streets in protest for a second Friday
that's despite warnings from Egyptian
security forces that they would face a
harsh response al-jazeera cannot
independently verify these videos but
they are said to be in kena a city in
Upper Egypt and also in el warrick near
the capital Cairo other reports suggests
a large security presence in central
Cairo with the streets virtually
deserted the Roadster square which has
been the heart of previous protests over
the years blocked off another narrative
in what is just as much a media campaign
state television showing pro-government
protests in the capital president Abdul
Fattah el-sisi returned to Cairo earlier
on Friday from the UN General Assembly
in New York this welcome posted on his
official Facebook page where the
president reassures this crowd that all
is well what are you doing here why you
got up early on a Friday morning life is
good and easy you have to know that the
Egyptians are very aware of how they try
to fake the realities tell unrealistic
things and deceive the people for the
sake of Allah and for the sake of you
what happened before will never happen
again don't worry and don't be worried
good morning to you but despite the
president's assurances something is
happening here putting out troops all
over the streets of Cairo and Alexandria
to do random checks all over the city is
a very clear reflection of this
government's insecurity of the fact that
the thing that threatens this government
more than anything else is the voice of
its own people a government that it's
secure in its standing that secure its
legitimacy and its support among the
Egyptian public wouldn't be so
frightened or terrified by hundreds of
protesters in the streets of Cairo it
started with this man Mohammed Ali a
contractor for the Egyptian military for
15 years the largest and most powerful
institution in the country recently
breaking rank uploading video statements
from Spain where he now lives in
self-imposed exile accusing senior
military leaders of wasting millions of
dollars to build villas palaces and
hotels it hasn't gone down well with
many who are finding it hard to live
Dave
more recently there's a lot of economic
discontent CC's economic policies have
mostly failed the wealth gap has
increased and Egypt's poverty rate is
rising pretty dramatically hundreds came
out to protest last Friday and what has
been the biggest show of discontent
against CeCe's rule Human Rights Watch
says nearly 2,000 people have been
arrested in the last week alone
al-jazeera is banned from reporting
inside the country the bigger picture of
what is happening here may take time to
become clear but it seems once again
Egyptians have lost their fear and are
defying orders to remain silent
Stephanie Decker al-jazeera